y si la producción es un ultimátum
destinado a impulsar la moneda rusa pero
también a contraatacar las sanciones
occidentales
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
confirmó que a partir del primero de
abril los países inamistosos como los
califica tendrán que pagar su gas en
rublos o se quedarán en la energía rusa
si estos pagos no tienen éxito lo
consideraríamos como un incumplimiento
de los compromisos por parte de los
compradores que tendrán que asumir las
consecuencias a nosotros nadie nos vende
nada gratis tampoco vamos a hacer obras
de caridad esto significa que los
contratos actuales se paralizarían y
esto sí contract group hasta rusia
suministra alrededor del 40 por ciento
del gas de europa lo que convierte a la
energía en la palanca más poderosa que
tiene rusia para hacer frente a las
sanciones occidentales
impuestas por la invasión a ucrania el
nuevo decreto firmado por putin exigiría
que los pagos del gas pasen por el banco
estatal ruso gazprombank los gobiernos
europeos lo rechazaron como un intento
de chantaje y un incumplimiento de sus
contratos
y
hemos examinado los contratos sobre el
gas y otros suministros en ellos se
establece que el pago es en euros a
veces en dólares pero normalmente en
euros
le dije al presidente ruso que seguiría
siendo así habrá que ver sus acciones
ahora pero lo que está claro es que las
empresas quieren y pagarán en euros para
rafael félix fernández y luego tal cual
con bondad
aunque la unión europea no se fundó a
eeuu en la prohibición del uso de la
energía rusa el bloque planea reducir
las importaciones de gas en dos tercios
de este año pero las opciones de
alternativas son limitadas
francia y alemania- dicen que se están
preparando para una posible interrupción
del suministro mientras alemania y
austria los más dependientes del gas
ruso y han activado planes de emergencia
que podrían llevar a un racionamiento